Es que en aquella, o sea, lo digo porque
en aquellas donde donde ya hemos hecho
el temario, lo que vamos a hacer es un
repaso de todo lo que se ha dado,
así de cara al examen.
Te voy a pasar, Jorge, esto que lo tenía
antes abierto.
Sí, te lo paso en el A ver.
Vale, te lo paso, eh, por aunque sea por
aquí por el chat.
A ver cómo queda enmaquetado. Vale, esto
sería para utilizar SAM con con
WordPress
que lo has conseguido, ¿vale? Pero
te lo había buscado antes
porque supongo que le has puesto a la
base de datos para para acceder a la
base de datos el usuario rot
sin contraseña,
por ejemplo, ¿o no te acuerdas?
Sí, puede ser. H,
vale, pues con eso tendrías
y luego nada, o sea, tira de tutoriales
por ahí que hay un montonazo.
Bueno, hay un montón. Si para dentro de
unas semanitas una página decente,
una página decente seguro si te coges
algún tutorial de esos de paso a paso de
alguien que no sea muy muy
romancero, o sea, a ver, porque hay
realmente es que hay tutoriales que
se tiran la mitad del tiempo
hablando de otras cosas.
Vale, aquí he descargado el
A ver, unidad uno
que sería un resumen. A ver si a ver si
me lo abre.
Vale, con PowerPoint
solo una vez.
Vale, no llegamos a verlo. Pues sí
podríamos verlo. Venga, sí, ¿por qué no?
Vamos a echarle ahí un vistacillo a
este.
Un segundo
que voy a ver también
en qué en qué situación estábamos,
porque yo creo que sí que lo habíamos
que habíamos llegado hasta el final.
Sí,
estamos en el tema tres ya. El otro día
ya hicimos un ejercicio, ¿no?, de
en el que utilizamos DHCP, DNS, HTTP y
FTP,
que aunque realmente no es es para que
viéramos más más que nada cómo funciona.
Exacto.
Sí, porque estamos hablando ahí de
conceptos, ¿no? De de siglas y tal,
decir, "Oye, pues esto es por esto."
Vale, vamos un poquito a hacer repaso y
vamos a ver hm
una presentación. A ver,
vista.
Voy a configurar para que no vaya
por su cuenta. Vale,
20 páginas y no va por su cuenta,
parece.
Vale, no lo había puesto ahí. Vale, es
que estaba mirando esta pantalla.
Vale, vale. Pues sería Sí que se ve,
¿no?
Sí.
Vale,
vale. Pues eh es un repaso. Os voy a
quitar de aquí.
Os pongo ahí arrios,
¿vale? Sistema microinformáticos y
redes, ¿vale? Redes locales, ¿vale? ¿Qué
es una red de computadores? es un
conjunto de dos o más equipos o
dispositivos informáticos conectados
entre sí con el objetivo de comunicarse
y compartir recursos. Como veis, ostras,
mira,
una
el PDA,
una PDA de estas
parecida, además, eh, a la que veis que
este sería el sistema operativo, es el
Windows Mobile,
eh, vale, conjunto de dos o más equipos,
¿vale? Pues eso, o sea, no
necesariamente tiene que ser una
recable, o sea, realmente podría ser
puede ser alámbrica, puede ser cable,
¿vale? Y y bueno, el objetivo es ese,
comunicación,
comunicación y compartición.
¿Vale? ¿Qué es una red de computadores?
Es un En una comunicación en red
intervienen los siguientes elementos.
sería el emisor,
el receptor, el código, o sea, el
mensaje. Eh,
el mensaje está estaría,
o sea, no codificado, sino que
codificado realmente significaría que
está
que lleva una
que lleva una a ver un sistema de
seguridad, ¿no? O sea, no estamos
hablando de eso, ¿no?
Vale. Y luego tendríamos el canal o
medio de transmisión.
Vale.
Vale. Según su extensión estuvimos
hablando que que estaban las LAN la
local area network,
o sea, quiero decir redes de área local
con una extensión que va desde los
equipos interconectados
hasta una red distribuida en varios
edificios próximos entre sí. O sea, o
sea, realmente el significado de esto
sería cercanía,
o sea, es eh, por ejemplo,
intercomunicar dos municipios no sería
una red local
o aunque estuviésemos dentro de una
comarca o dentro de una provincia,
¿vale? Eso no no sería una red local, o
sea, estamos hablando de extensiones
extensiones en el desde la escala humana
extensiones cercanas
edificios contiguos, por ejemplo,
edificios dentro de una empresa,
a ver, por ejemplo, así, una empresa
tocha, por ejemplo, la Ford, todos
habréis visto la Ford, que es que es es
bastante grande, ¿no? cuando cuando
paséis por allí, ellos realmente eh lo
que tienen es una, o sea, es la red que
tienen dentro de la for es una red de
área local, dividían muchísimas sus
redes, cada una ir a un departamento y
tal, pero no estamos hablando de de Y
eso que la extensión del edificio, o
sea, del edificio, ¿no? El recinto es
bastante grande.
Vale, MAN o Metropolitan Area Network
con una extensión que abarca una ciudad,
generalmente suelen ser redes de
proveedores de servicios
y One red de área extensa, cualquier red
de extensión superior, una más, incluso
de ámbito mundial,
¿vale? realmente la, o sea, que es a lo
que
a lo que se refiere esta esta asignatura
sería redes locales. Estamos hablando
esto sería nuestra liga, ¿vale? Para
esta asignatura
sin
dejar de lado, pues que esto que estas
también existen, ¿vale? Pero nosotros
nos vamos a centrar en esta.
¿Veis?
Aquí gráficamente pues también queda
bastante bastante definido,
¿vale? Los tipos de redes, supongo que
ahora también, ¿vale? Según su medio de
transmisión basadas en cobre, utilizan
cables de cobre y la información se
transmite en forma de impulsos
eléctricos. En redes se usan
principalmente
los cables coaciales y el par trenzado.
¿Sabéis lo que es el cable coacial?
El sería el típico cable de antena
de antena de televisión. Eso sería un
cable ecuacial.
basadas en fibra óptica emplean fibra
óptica eh una fibra de vidrio
debidamente acondicionada que transporta
la información en forma de luz.
Vale, luego está varios tipos de de
fibras ópticas, pero ay, a ver, vale,
me pasaba la pantalla, ¿vale? Y luego
están las inalámbricas. El medio de
transmisión es el aire eliminando los
cables. Algunas tecnologías inalámbricas
son los infrarrojos, las redes basadas
en estándares 802.11
como el WiFi o el Bluetooth.
El reciente reciente no, pero
llevo ya unos añitos con nosotros los de
Bluetooth.
Ah, sí. A ver. Creo que es más re. A
ver, ya simplemente por curiosidad, ¿eh?
¿Cuándo cuándo sale el Bluetooth?
Pero desconozco el dato y es importante,
hombre, todas estas cosas.
Bluetooth. Sale. A ver, Wikipedia.
Bluetooth
introducido el 7 de mayo del 98
y el wifi. O sea, claro, a ver, una cosa
es introducido y otra cuando se
estandariza también,
que a lo mejor
se inventa tal y lo utiliza el Bill
Gates y su familia hasta que en 10 años
dice, "Venga, va, que lo voy a soltar al
mundo."
Y luego tenemos wifi,
Wikipedia. A ver,
introducido, pues a la par, eh,
así, sin entrar más en detalle, WiFi se
introduce el 21 de septiembre del 98
y Bluetooth el 7 de mayo del 98.
A mí ya os digo que que es que no me
suena así de Claro, cuando he visto la
he visto la reciente tecnología
Bluetooth me digo, "Ostra, pero si es
que es bast tiene bastante tiempo,
Vale, Bluetooth, eh, como tal. Claro, a
ver, realmente no se estandarizó, nos
estandarizó hasta hasta bastante
hasta bastante tarde. Pues aunque sí que
aparece, sí que nos pone aquí que
aparece en esas
en esas épocas, me imagino que es cuando
se dictamina que el estándar de
Bluetooth es es tal y cual,
eh, pero pero ya os digo que no. Sí que
es verdad que que en algunas PDAs y eso
sí que sí que tenían Bluetooth también,
¿vale? en los, hombre,
en manos libres de vehículos, la verdad
es que se utiliza desde hace muchísimo.
Bueno, no deja de ser un dato más,
¿vale? Que es
que bueno, no está de más,
pero aquí sí que tendríamos el estándar
y 1 B. Y luego a partir del 1.1 daos
cuenta que estamos por el cinco. Creo
recordar
el 4 aparece en 2010
y el 5.2 5.4
23.
Vale, pues cada en cada en cada versión
de Bluetooth se va implementando una
nueva característica.
A saber.
Ahora está por el 5.4.
Sí, el c
el 54 en el en el 23.
Aquí se implementa comunicación
bidireccional segura entre un punto de
acceso inalámbrico y miles de nodos
finales de muy baja potencia.
menor consumo, o sea, en cada cada
versión va aumentando, ¿no? Las
capacidades va implementando.
Y wifi realmente
sí que es un estándar desde el momento
que que aparece,
o sea,
está el señor que lo inventa,
digo yo.
estándares 802
eso, o sea, con los estándares con el
El
al principio recuerdo que estaban el
estaban, o sea, lo que te encontrabas
por defecto en todos los routers y tal
era el B. Luego ya apareció N,
el estándar N, que ya
a partir de ahí sí que empieza a
más velocidad todo.
Con wifi pasaban cosas como que, por
ejemplo, te encontrabas con que ibas con
tu portátil. A lo mejor yo, esto me pasó
en Francia, fui con fui con mi portátil,
yo todo contento allí, dijo, "¿Me puedo
conectar por wifi tal?" Esto y no me
podía conectar porque el estándar del
router no era el de no era el estándar
de, o sea, yo tenía pues no recuerdo
Bog, ¿vale? el de mi el mi el de la
tarjeta de R de mi de mi portátil y allí
estaba emitiendo en N, algo así, una un
rollo de esos y decía, "Pero, hombre,
¿cómo puede ser? Tal no es que tal que
decía, pues cámbialo.
No, no, no color.
Sí, posib creo que era eso. Sí,
vale.
Basadas en bueno, esto lo hemos visto,
basadas en fibra óptica inalámbricas.
Estábamos en en ilalámbricas y de ahí el
de ahí esto que hemos estado comentando.
Vale. Siguiente. Tipos de redes. Cable
coasial. ¿Veis? Se parece. Bueno, el
cable coasial realmente es es lo que se
utilizaría.
Eh,
eso lo tenéis muy, o sea, si veis cable
de televisión, pues sería este
luego el parter entrado y el de fibra
óptica.
Vale, según su topología, vale, esto sí
que
sí que esto me imagino que sí que vale,
bien las topologías aquí, ¿vale?
Tipos de redes según su topología de
maya totalmente conectada, todos los
equipos de la red están conectados entre
sí. Ventajas, comunicación directa entre
cada par de equipos, inconvenientes,
alto coste de ampliación. Posiblemente,
a ver, os lo digo ya para el examen, eh,
tendréis que simular alguna alguna
topología, ya no digo una o dos, o sea,
no sé no sé cuántas, pero alguna que
otras sí que sí que tendréis que
crearlas con el packet tracer.
Vale, o sea, entonces lo vamos a tocar
mucho en el examen, eh,
mucho no vamos a tocarlo, o sea, porque
a ver, realmente es redes locales de
primero, es muy teórico todo.
O sea, yo, claro, de hecho, incluso yo
no sé tú cuando cuando estuviste en
primero, yo sé que hacía bastante,
pero en la primera evaluación tocaste
vale, está bien.
Yo vamos, casi mi teoría. Sí,
fue todo
eso para no aburriros.
No sé yo.
Un mismo la más, ¿no? Que tienes ahí un
Es que con el Paquet Tracer
es que Packet Tracer es muy ladrillo el
programa. Es la verdad es que a ver lo
que más informática, sin duda,
eh,
¿qué es lo que más oído informática?
Lo que pasa luego, a ver, Packet tracer
y la realidad
no hay mucho. ¿Cuál es?
Está bien para que te hacer.
Bueno, todos los equipos de la red están
conectados entre sí, ¿vale? En la malla
totalmente conectada. Ventajas,
comunicación directa entre cada par de
equipos.
inconvenient. A ver, yo tengo una guía
realmente de de que implementéis todo, o
sea, tengo el tutoriales de que
implementéis todos los todo lo que se
puede hacer con packet tracer, ¿vale? Lo
que pasa que soltarlo así de buenas a
primeras en la primera evaluación no lo
he visto producente, vamos,
visto contraproducente casi,
¿vale? Pero sí que sí que claro, tú
realmente tú vienes tú ahora estás en
segundo, estaréis tocando algo para que
tr
no tocáis nada
ahora ya lo hacemos.
Vale, pero si estuvieras a distancia
realmente sí que estarías tocando claro.
Y durante todo primero también estuviste
tocando. Entonces tú lo tienes bastante
bastante asimilado, ¿no? El el tema de
Packet Trer. Pero claro, los alumnos que
vienen de de cero que nunca ha tocado
esto, pues
ya
es bastante difícil,
¿no? No, sí es sí es complicado. Sí, la
verdad es que
es complicado y te y hace que te
que
información. Sí, sí. Es que es claro,
claro. O sea, es que depende cómo se se
es que esto es complejo.
Bueno, realmente lo que nos gusta es
cacharrear. Es así, ¿no? O sea, que si
coges instalas este sistema, haces esto,
lo otro, soy estudiar, soy más que
hacerlo ya.
Ahí estamos.
Ya, pero los exámenes están ahí. Es que
claro,
probar un sistema, probar un procesador,
esta, le quito esta memoria, le pongo
esta, tal. Sí,
eso es lo que casi todo el mundo se va
informática. Claro,
yo porque quiero saber las topologías,
yo no quiero saber eso. Yo no enchufo
donde me venga y la gana.
Bueno, topología maya totalmente
conectada. Todos los equipos de la red
están conectados entre sí. Ventajas,
comunicación directa entre cada par de
equipos. Inconvenientes, alto coste de
ampliación poco adecuada para redes
numerosas. Claro, imaginar el lío de
cables, ¿no? También, por ejemplo, el
lío de
Si hablamos de Sí, eso. O sea, imaginar
el galo de conexiones.
Malla parcialmente conectada. Los
equipos de la red que tienen una mayor
necesidad de comunicación están
conectados entre sí. Ventajas. mejor,
menor cantidad de conexiones, coste de
ampliación relativamente bajo, puede
valer para redes más numerosas.
Inconvenientes, no siempre hay
comunicación directa entre equipos. Por
ejemplo, entre este y este sí que lo
hay, pero entre este y este no lo hay.
Es necesario incluir en cada equipo
herramientas para conocer los caminos de
la red.
Este es lo mismo. Entre este y este no
tenemos. Entre este y este sí. Para
llegar a este tenemos que venir por aquí
o tenemos que venir por aquí.
Este se queda así como aislado. Bueno,
pues eso es un poco como inconexa, ¿no?
Vale, de anillo. Cada equipo de la red
está conectado con dos equipos.
Este está con este, con este, este, con
este, con este, este a su vez con este,
con este. Formando una cadena cerrada.
Ventajas, baja, baja cantidad de
conexiones, coste de ampliación muy
bajo. Inconvenientes, no siempre hay
comunicación directa entre equipos. Un
corte, una conexión puede hacer caer a
toda la red.
Estrella. Cada equipo de la red está
conectado en un único equipo
intermediario que glutea las conexiones
y controla la red. Ventajas. Baja
cantidad de conexiones. Coste de
ampliación muy bajo. La comunicación es
casi directa entre cada par de equipos.
Solo pasa por el entre cada par de
equipos solo pasa por el central. La
gestión de la red no recae en los
equipos finales. Inconvenientes. La
caída del equipo intermediario hace caer
toda la red.
Se crea el servidor y se va todo a hacer
puñetas.
Vale. Todos los equipos de de la red
están unidos por un medio de transmisión
común o Bush.
Ventajas. Mínima cantidad de conexiones,
coste de ampliación muy bajo. La
comunicación es directa entre cada par
de equipos.
La gestión de la red no reca los equipos
finales.
Inconvenientes. Mientras el bus está
ocupado por dos equipos comunicándose,
el resto debe esperar a que quede libre.
La caída del bus hace caer toda la red.
Vale, pues esas serían las
más las más básicas,
¿vale? Elementos físicos de una red,
los equipos finales. Tenemos por un lado
los equipos finales que también llamados
host host o nodos. Son aquellos equipos
que actúan como emisores o receptores de
comunicación de una red.
Tenemos ordenadores, smartphone,
impresoras de red, teléfonos de WIP,
cámaras de red, PDAs, tablets,
servidores, etcétera.
Equipos intermediums
son aquellos equipos que ayudan a
transportar la información por la red.
Por ejemplo, dispositivos de acceso a
red que conectan dispositivos finales en
una red, apps, switch y puntos de acceso
inalámbricos.
Dispositivos de Internetwor conectando
sumas redes distintas entre sí. Serían
los routers.
Servidores de comunicación
a partir de una señal de banda ancha
ofrecen servicios como telefonía,
televisión, fax, etcétera. Fax, la
verdad es que se utiliza hoy en día,
está muy muy de capa caída ya el fax,
eh, a 2025.
Hubo un tiempo en que la comunicación
era por fax, básicamente, pero pero
claro, eso ya pasó.
De hecho, o sea, a la hora de
a la hora de darte de baja de algún de,
por ejemplo, de ONO y de y de compañías
así, necesitabas enviar un fax. tenías
que claro, o sea, yo solía hacer este
tipo de cosas con la con la impresora
que tenía la opción de de FAS, pero si
no le tocaba ir a
a una papelería y te cobraba lo que lo
que querían.
Vale, models conectan equipos entre sí a
través de redes telefónicas o de cable
y dispositivos de seguridad. Ofrecen
protección y monitorización de la red
cortafuegos firewalls.
Vale, estos serían en el los
equipos intermedios.
Vale, tendríamos los oíamos estado
mirando los equipos finales y los
equipos intermedos
intermediarios.
Elementos físicos de una, ¿vale? Los
hubs, también llamados concentradores.
Estuvimos viendo la diferencia al
principio de los tiempos en la
asignatura entre Hub y switch
y cómo y cómo
hacía uso de los paquetes. Lo estuvimos
viendo en Packet Tracer,
¿vale? que que el hub realmente se lo
enviaba a todo a todo Kisky en la red,
mientras que el Switch sí que sí que era
un dispositivo bastante inteligente,
¿no? En ese sentido, porque realmente
nos lo enviaba a donde a donde nosotros
queríamos que lo enviase, o sea, a su
destinatario.
Hubs, también llamados concentradores,
son dispositivos intermediarios que
aglutinan físicamente con red en un
medio eléctrico común, comportándose
como una topología en bus, aunque
parezca una estrella. Cuando en un
equipo final intenta comunicarse con
otro, se puede producir una colisión si
el bus está ocupado y tendrá que esperar
a que se libere.
Aunque están desuso hoy día, aún siguen
empleándose como snifers, analizadores
de protocolos, programas de programa de
captura las tramas de una red para
eh para monitorizar, perdón, el tráfico
de las redes.
Vale. Switch,
también llamados conmutadores son
dispositivos intermediarios que
aglutinan físicamente conexiones de red.
y establecen
eh
canales de comunicación independientes
entre cada par de equipos finales,
formando una red con topología de
estrella,
dan un rendimiento muy superior a los H,
puesto que no producen colisiones y hoy
día se emplean masivamente.
Al igual que los HS, los switch se
pueden apilar entre sí para conseguir un
mayor número de conexiones.
¿Vale? siguiente.
El PowerPoint este realmente lo tenéis
en los materiales. Eh, lo digo por si
queréis
os sirve para repasar cosas, pues
también está bien.
Vale. puntos de acceso inalámbricos,
también llamadas APAP, son dispositivos
intermediarios que permiten a los
equipos finales el acceso a una red a
través de radiofrecuencia.
Routers, también llamados pasalelas,
puertas de enlace o o gateway, son eh eh
dispositivos
intermediarios que unen dos o más redes
distintas. Son muy conocidos los que nos
venden los ISP, proveedores de internet
para conectar nuestra lada a internet.
Hombre, este no se parece precisamente
al que nos da el señor Vodafone cuando
o DJ cuando nos cuando,
o sea, el que nos pone por defecto, no
no sería ese, sería sería algo más
parecido a esto
con varios puertos.
O sea, me refiero al aspecto físico, eh,
de lo que sería un router. Bueno, todos
tenéis en mente un router.
Este sería pues eso, un router para un
para instalarlo en un en un armario, en
un rack.
Vale. Eh, elementos físicos de una red,
¿vale? El acceso a servidores a través
de la red telefónica básica se realiza a
través de mods
que convierte en la información digital
en señal eléctrica válida para la red
telefónica y viceversa.
Desde el moden hasta la roseta va un
cable telefónico con conectores RJ11 de
cuatro contactos. Solo se usan dos.
Model interno PCI a la izquierda y
modelo externo a la derecha. Algunos
internos son del tipo win modem PC o MR,
cuyas funciones
son realizadas por el sistema operativo
en vez de por su propio hardware. Los
externos son más fiables.
Bueno, está
en a través de esto sí que podías enviar
un un fax realmente como se conectaba a
la red telefónica.
Ahora la red telefónica fija,
¿vale? 19 relación entre
by civit por segundo y sus múltiplos.
Pues nada, aquí tenéis una una tabla,
¿vale? que está interesante. Repito, hm,
lo tenéis en la en la en la primera
unidad de la asignatura. Tenéis esta
tenéis esta este PowerPoint,
¿vale? Y por último tenemos las capas
del modelo OSI,
¿vale? La capa física transmite el flujo
de de bit sin procesar a través del
medio físico.
La capa de enlace de datos define el
formato de los datos en la red. La capa
de red decide la ruta física que
seguirán los datos. La capa de
transporte transmite datos mediante
protocolos de transmisión incluidos TCP
y UDP. La capa de sesión mantiene las
conexiones y es responsable de controlar
puertos y sesiones. La capa de
presentación
garantizar que los datos tenga un
formato utilizable y es donde se
encriptan los datos. y la capa de
aplicación, capa de interacción hombre
máquina donde las aplicaciones pueden
acceder a los servicios de
Vale, tenéis una un resumen bastante
bastante guay de
todo lo que lo que hemos dado en ese
primer, bueno, realmente va un poquito
más allá de esa primera unidad.
Luego tenemos la dos, la unidad dos que
nos habla del cableado,
la instalación física de una reda. Ver
cables trenzados, características de las
señales, IPV4, tarjeta de red.
Voy a ver también los ejercicios que
hicimos con Packet Tracer
porque sí que hemos hecho, a ver,
estuvimos haciendo cuatro iniciales para
Es que vosotros no vinisteis desde el
primer día vosotros de, o sea, porque
vosotros realmente
vinisteis a la asignatura,
o sea, vosotros tres que estáis en
segundo,
vinisteis ya ha empezado, o sea, sobre
final de mediados de No, no lo
sé. No, no sabría decirte.
A ver, empezamos cuando empezaron las
clases normales, así que
es que desde el primer día no estáis eh
en la Claro, vendéis posiblemente al la
quinta clase o así que ya habíamos
empezado
7 de septiembre que fuimos.
A ver, él nosotros empezamos
la semana que viene empezamos
empezasteis en presencial.
Y esa semana no no acabó el miércoles.
Claro.
Y a la siguiente ya sí que empezamos.
En la siguiente ya empezasteis que
vinisteis. Sí, vale. Cierto. O sea,
estuvisteis dos semanas realmente.
Sí.
Sin sin, o sea, empezasteis a las dos
semanas.
Sí, sería eso.
Yo creo que ahí porque mira, el 19 de
del nueve es cuando ya yo me descargué
me descargué los ejercicios de Cisco
y empezamos por el uno, por ejemplo. O
sea, y era así bastante sencillete de
todo.
Era más que nada pues saber dónde dónde
estaba. ¿Queréis que lo repasemos esto o
cómo lo veis? Decidme, Jorge y compañía,
¿qué qué os parece?
Represar Cisco.
Sí.
A ver, a mí me gustaría ver el tema de
hacer una una topología dentro de Cisco.
Sí, ¿no?
Sí, como no sé, la
la malla. Vale, podríamos hacer de maya
por poner una, eh, o sea,
¿vale?
y que sea funcional, obviamente,
¿no? Porque nos podemos poner ahí a
poner dispositivos
sin ton ni son.
Sí, para que funcione básicamente.
A ver, yo en un principio hablaba de
hablaba de de representaciones, ¿vale?
No, no hablaba de Vamos a representar eh
una, o sea, ¿cómo lo representas? Pues
mediante host, ¿vale? Diferentes host
unidos de tal manera que la queremos
hacer eh funcional,
pues sí que sí que estaría bien preparar
el ejercicio. Lo miro si queréis y
mañana lo y mañana lo preparamos.
Pero en el examen, ¿cómo va a salir el
tema de de topologías?
Yo en un principio, o sea, a ver, yo con
que sepáis cómo
eh Claro, es que no es que tenemos dos
opciones,
eh hacerlo que sea funcional,
funcional en base a protocolos, ¿vale?
Y otra es que que representemos como es
una topología.
Esas serían las dos opciones que
tenemos. Yo creo que con la
representación vamos bien para esta
primeración.
Sí, sí. Creo que creo que con eso vamos
bien, porque es que si no también es
cargarnos de mucho.
Es que yo yo pensaba que ibas a poner lo
de hacer una funcional en Cesco y por
eso te había dicho ese
Es que claro, yo no me he preparado nada
tampoco en ese sentido, entonces tampoco
quiero ponerme aquí que no salga bien y
que no funcione, ¿no?
Que eso me da mucha rabia.
Mira, vamos a hacer una que algo que sí
que funciona.
¿Qué se me está ocurriendo ahora?
Si abre el cisco este.
Lo tenemos. Vale, vendíamos, por
ejemplo, vale, el otro día, ¿os acordáis
que estuvimos mirando el tema de
redes? Estuvimos haciendo esta.
Vale, yo ahora lo que podríamos hacer
porque esta sí que es completamente
funcional, aquí tenemos un servidor DNS
y tenemos un servidor http y FTP.
Espera,
déjame pensar, eh, un poquillo. No.
A ver si con este me deja.
Estoy viendo un documento que que sí que
viene con con ejercicios, ¿vale?
Entonces sí que podríamos tirar de aquí,
que es una manera, la verdad es que es
una manera de aprender las topologías
bien.
A ver,
tenemos
ver, voy a probar esta que sería una una
topología de bus o lineal.
Vale, a ver qué tal
qué tal sale.
Vale. Y aquí luego en las
en las IPs de cada equipo
estarían dentro de la misma
la configuramos como estática, por
ejemplo, y a este le ponemos
lo típico 192.18
punto 1 punto pues esta lo ponemos como
dos, ¿vale? máscara de de red. Eso sería
una una IP de tipo C.
¿De acuerdo? La siguiente, nos vamos y
le ponemos la tres.
Punto 168.1.3.
Acá bien.
Siguiente.
Números.
168.1.4
siguiente
192.168.1.5.
nos calcula la
máscara redet y esta sería la
6.168
punto
1 que iba a seis, ¿no? La otra cinco.
Sí, creo que sí.
Vale, tendríamos ya esto.
Vale, en teoría debería de funcionar.
nos tenemos los tenemos los equipos en
la misma red
y vamos a probar a enviar eh pues un
mensaje de este
a este y okay, ¿vale? Tenemos una red
funcional
en la que hemos implementado una una
topología de bus o lineal,
¿vale? Esta sería válida, por ejemplo,
para el
para el para el examen.
Vale, pues vamos a poner. Venga, pues
podemos
podemos hacer todas
aprenderoslas
o innovar también. ¿Qué se puede hacer
con esto? ¿Se puede hacer con más cosas?
Topología
eh
bus o lineal.
Vale.
Está puesta como no. Vale, voy a poner
esta
eh
Vale.
Vale, vamos a hacer una en
una en estrella, ¿vale?
Vale, cogemos, por ejemplo,
Vamos a hacerlo con con
cinco ordenadores y una impresora, por
ejemplo. M.
y con un ordenadorcillo también
portátil
y una impresorilla.
Eh,
esa puerta no va no va bien. Es
cuánta gente, ¿no? Sí, de repente.
Vale,
vale. Metemos un switch por aquí
y tiramos de
a ver cuántos tiene este.
Está bien.
A ver, cuando se haga un ejercicio, por
ejemplo, de Paquet tracer, está muy bien
el tema de que
etiquetéis todo el máximo posible.
O sea, todo aquello que consideréis
que hay que tiquetarlo, etiquetarlo.
Vale, pues aquí volvemos a a
lo mismo.
Pues nada, estamos
192.168.
1.2
1 no me 2.68.1.3
192 pun
168.1.4.68.1.5
C.
Pero, ¿qué es qué es lo que habéis hecho
con
este Álvaro en las en la Claro, es que
yo quiero es saber
a a ver qué nivel
eh habéis hecho eh
redes de HCP, por ejemplo, o sea,
estamos haciendo
en primero. Hablo en primero, creo.
Primero,
claro, claro,
claro. que es por eso que es que estamos
en primero
realmente.
Las topologías sí que me acuerdo.
Topología, sí, porque eso sí que los
tiempos de los cables,
eh, y no me acuerdo mucho más, ¿no? Es
que es que todo es un poquito teoría,
¿no? Realmente en primero por eso.
Claro, para que traces, sí, pero
es que claro, tú esto luego lo tienes
que que extrapolar realmente a la vida
real.
Vale, este sería el cinco.
Hace hace fresco,
¿no? Que hace más,
¿no? Que si eso lo
nada
lo subo un poco, ¿eh? Hasta 24.
Sí, por estar más. Vale, vale.
Vale. Una 2.168.1.
1.6 creo que era la siguiente.
2 3 4 5 6 Sí. Y la Y por último tenemos
la impresora
estática. A ver.
92.168.1.7.
Vale,
tenamos esto sería la configuración,
sería esta de aquí. Vale.
Eh, en principio
no nos debería de funcionar.
Vamos aquí.
y okay, ¿vale?
O nos le enviamos desde el uno a la
impresora y también acá.
Vale, realmente
configurar como DHCP
un a la hora de hacer topologías,
a ver, luego a la hora de corregir
eh realmente, o sea, tú cuando asignas,
imaginar que aquí tenemos un servidor,
¿vale?, que está on router que está que
está diciendo, "Vale, todos vosotros
vais a estar en este rango de
direcciones IP y os lo voy a ir
asignando." Cuando tú abres Packet
Tracer, primero te tienes que esperar un
poquillo hasta que asigna todas.
Segundo, este de aquí posiblemente ahora
tiene la IP tal. Si lo ponemos en DCHP,
a lo mejor no tiene esta y tiene otra, o
sea, cada vez va a tener una diferente.
Si nosotros, por ejemplo, como queremos
hacer muy bien el ejercicio, lo que
hacemos es etiquetamos y decimos, este
tiene la etiqueta, este tiene esta IP
tal y este tiene esta otra. ¿Por qué?
Pues por si yo quiero hacer un pin,
¿vale? Imagínate que yo digo pin
al quiero hacer un pin a este que sé que
tiene esta dirección IP porque me lo ha
puesto aquí Álvaro, por ejemplo, con una
etiqueta. ¿Vale? Entonces digo 192.168.1
1 punto este sería el cinco,
perdón, cinco. Pero es que claro, si un
servidor de HCP no nos lo va a hacer en
ese en este orden que nosotros lo hemos
puesto la primera vez, nos lo va a hacer
como él la como él le parezca
en paquetra,
¿vale? Y ahí sí que tenemos que
que no se que sí que hay que sí que hay
una conexión realmente. O sea, es la
otra manera tenemos de averiguar que ese
paquete está llegando realmente
al cinco. Este es el cinco, ¿no?
Sí, este es el cinco.
Vale, pues eso, esta sería. Voy a
hacerla así. Vamos a intentar hacer
todas y así.
Pues nada, interiorizarlo a la hora de
del examen, ¿vale? Este tipo de me
parece un buen un buen sistema. Este,
Jorge, me parece me parece un buen
sistema este a la hora de
aprender un poquito más, ¿no? Sobre
topologías,
¿sí?
Y si cualquiera de esas eh tiene una a
pipa, no se puede hacer pin, ¿no?
Vamos a probarlo, pero me da a mí que
no.
O sea, a ver, ¿te refieres a que estén
todas en la pipa o que solo haya una que
no esté?
No, que que solo haya una en pipa y se
intenta hacer ping,
¿no? ¿Verdad?
Vamos a quitarlo. Yo digo que no.
Lo ponemos en DHP.
Vale, ya está en la pipa. ¿Por qué?
Porque no está en la misma red.
Realmente entiende que no está en la
misma. Otra cosa, esa es la teoría. Otra
cosa es que te digas, "Sí, sí, que sí
que le llega." ¿Ves? Te ha fallado.
No está en la misma red. Entiende que no
está en la misma.
Hm.
Vale, lo que sí que me molaría probar es
que estén todas Es que claro, es una
lástima quitar quitar todas las Voy a
voy a quitar esta también.
Bueno, no, esta no, que era más
complicadilla de Bueno, venga, la quito
también.
Entonces ahora entre dos apipas
va a entender que que está en la misma
red y posiblemente
entre esta ahí está.
Ahí sí.
Aquí sí que nos va a ir. Sí,
¿ves? Porque entiende que está en la
misma red, pero luego, o sea, si ahora
intentamos desde incluso desde este,
desde cualquiera de estos,
a ver,
a este de aquí, este ya está viipa y
este no, este estaría en la en una red
de clase C y no dice que ni de coña.
Vale, entonces nada.
Es como si aquí ponemos, ya verás,
¿vale? 192.168.1.7,
¿vale? Es la que tenía haciendo en un
primer momento. La entiende. Ay, espera
que esto, ¿dónde estoy?
Ostras, ¿qué he hecho? No, fuera esto de
aquí.
Vale, nos venimos aquí 192.168.1.7.
Entiende que es una una red de clase C,
¿vale? Nos pone ya
en la que eh en la que hasta cuántos
cuántos dispositivos podíamos conectar,
¿os acordáis?
¿En cuál?
Dime
en cuál
en en esta red que estamos creando en 1
pun 1.2.
Esta red de clase C
254,
¿no? Que no cuenta el cero y el
cor exacto. No cuenta el último ni el
primero.
Vale. Realmente así realmente sí que son
256 direcciones IP.
Pero útiles como tal serían
254.
254. Correcto. Vale, ahora vamos a hacer
el experimento de que tenemos
la printer,
la impresora, pero vale, cualquiera,
hasta la 254 nos serviría,
¿vale? Y le vamos a hacer, de hecho,
estamos aquí, esta es la 1 1.2.
Esta es la 1 2 5 4, ¿vale? Nosotros
tiramos de aquí un paquete hasta aquí,
nos dice, "Estupendo." Vale,
lo has conseguido. Vale, si ahora
nosotros nos venimos a la impresora y le
decimos
S2, simplemente
sigue siendo una red de clase C. ¿Qué
creéis? ¿Que que le va a llegar o que
no?
que no, porque no está en la en la misma
IP de red. No,
no está en la misma.
Claro, no entiende que no está en la
misma,
pero si pones las dos con la máscara 255
2500,
¿sí? ¿Verdad?
¿Cómo? ¿Cómo?
O sea, si le cambias la máscara de
subred
la tiene tiene la misma.
Ya, pero
si yo, claro, si yo ahora cojo y este
pongo un cero y en la otra un cero
también
pongo un cer Entonces sí que sí que
entiende que sí, que está en la misma
red y que además le caben 65,000
direcciones más
que se dice pronto.
Aquí sí que se Ahora nos la cargamos
esta.
Vale, nos venimos aquí,
¿ves? Y perfecto. Sin embargo,
si hacemos a cualquier otro,
así que nos las
cuándo sería
A
Bueno, decía yo ha estado ahí que se ha
venido arriba el programa.
Vale, sin esta sería la
cuatro.
A ver, desde aquí no me va a dejar que
no tiene consola
desde aquí. Ah, es que en esta sí que
estoy. Es que esto no se lo ha cambiado.
Se lo A ver. No, esto no se lo ha
cambiado. Ah, sí,
pero al tener el mismo uno se conecta.
Al tener ese mismo uno sí que se
conecta. Ya
lo entiende como
No, pero la verdad es que esto me, A
ver, este tiene
este tiene un dos, ¿no?
Si aquí le hemos puesto un dos. Vale,
vamos a Aquí vemos que sí que hay
conexión. Vale, si a este le ponemos
dos,
vemos que es de otra, eh, que que esto
sería una clase D, por ejemplo,
a una clase D. Y aquí sí que nos falla
al cambiar el
55.
Vale, esto lo dejamos como estaba.
Esto lo ponemos en un siete y aquí un
255.
Vale, vamos a Vale, aquí tendríamos.
Vale, está bien. Venga.
Topología
estrella.
Os lo os lo subiré, ¿vale?
Si no lo está tú me imaginas, Jorge, lo
estás haciendo, ¿no? Albert,
no
ahora no.
Si estuvieras aquí, sí.
Nos conocemos ya.
Eh, ¿puedes hacer una de Maya ahora?
A ver,
vale, este entiendo que me coge esto
mismo. Vale,
ahí
de malla.
Sí,
vamos a hacer de malla.
Hay que configurar los router por lo que
estoy viendo, ¿vale? Entonces eso va a
llevar más.
Si quieres la preparo, ¿vale? Mañana lo
vemos.
Vale. Sí,
sí, sí, sí. se prepara y mañana se ven
porque a ver
a ver si hay alguna así más sencilla. Es
que la que he visto es bastante bastante
compleja
y tampoco queréis cosas complejas, ¿no?
Así para el examen o qué.
No, no,
pues ahí estamos.
A ver, esto, hm, que podéis tardar 5
minutos, si te lo sabes, que puedes
tardar 5 minutos en hacerlo
por ahí
entre que lo pones y tal y lo maqueas
ahí para que quede para que quede chulo.
Las direcciones lo demás es fácil.
Claro, lo de las direcciones no liarte
ahí que con los nervios digas, ostras,
que es
otra cosa es el enunciado que ponga,
"Vale, tenéis que crear eh, claro,
imagínate que se me va la pinza y digo,
tenéis que crear un router que asigna
direcciones de de HCP." Claro que sí
que, ojo, lo estuvimos viendo el otro
día, ¿eh?
Eso ya no nos daría mucho tiempo.
Eso ya te va a ver
el examen ese y ya está un poco más.
Sí, ¿no? Porque que te salga la primera.
Es que ese es el problema de estas
cosas,
¿no? que se te falte un
Claro, que te has tenido algo que has
tenido algo que no lo has tenido en
cuenta y de repente dices, "Ostras, ya
se me va el tiempo.
A ver, estoy viendo No,
a ver,
esta no me mola. A ver, poner esta.
Hombre, tenemos una en topología de
árbol que es bastante chula.
Es con 10 switch en forma de pirámide,
tres debajo de uno y el resto seis
debajo de los tres. Buah, está chula y
sencilla, ¿vale? Y sí que nos ayuda a
ver cómo a ver cómo funciona todo esto,
¿vale? Y esta sí que nos da tiempo en 6
minutos.
Venga,
vale. Ponemos un switch aquí,
otro aquí, otro aquí
y otro al medio.
No son configurables,
o sea, son
eso no configurables
o directos. Vale, ponemos tres aquí.
A ver, vamos a todo esto. Lo
llevamos,
lo llevamos aquí. Esto lo llevamos aquí.
Este aquí, este aquí,
este aquí
y este aquí.
Vale. Y eh,
vale. Ponemos por ejemplo traca
este un portátil,
otro portátil.
Examená igual si ponemos portátil.
Mientras no lo ponga. Mientras no ponga.
Es como si, jolín, pues como si coges un
server, ¿no? Y lo pones en un servidor,
lo mismo. Al final es un host,
por ejemplo, no tendría a lo mejor mucho
sentido la configuración, pero bueno,
ahí está. Ahí te ayuda. Sí que te ayuda
realmente a
A ver.
Vale,
vale. Tenemos
todos estos cables realmente que está
que conectan estos switch, ¿qué serían?
¿Qué tipo de cables sería?
¿Sabéis alguien?
cruzado.
Un cruzado. Vale.
¿Por qué? Pues porque estamos hablando
de dispositivos con
con las mismas características.
Si nosotros conectamos este server y
este PC, ¿qué pondríamos?
Eh, cruzado también.
Un cable cruzado. Correcto. Sí, sí,
no lo vamos a hacer.
Lo cargamos. Claro, aquí eh por ejemplo,
pues para simular esto realmente
es más complicado el el dibujarlo que el
hacerlo eh realmente y luego el
asignarle las las direcciones IP.
Otra cosa es que es lo que lo que os
decía, o sea, imagínate que aquí ponemos
un un router y lo configuramos para que
asigne direcciones de HTP.
que esa podría ser otra opción. Eso
podría salir, por ejemplo, en el en el
enunciado del del examen, dependiendo si
hacemos una topología sencilla,
a lo mejor con esa esa propia sencillez
sí que sí que permite que yo, a ver, si
os si os dijera de de
que tenéis que que asignar dirección de
CHP mediante un router, por ejemplo, os
asignaría los
os Os pondría en el enunciado, ¿qué
comandos tenéis que poner en la en el
CLI? Vale, como los tienes,
porque es que
claro, es que no te tiene, ¿cómo te vas
a saber todo? Es que no
es eso. Hay algunos que se creen no se
hacen aprenderlos y eso
es que yo lo veo,
eso es una burrada.
Yo lo veo yo creo que es más interesante
que os sepáis que
hacer todo el proceso el código
aprender.
Es que el código, si es que se te
olvida, si es que es que es así.
Es que los únicos que te tienes que más
o menos aprender en punto, por ejemplo,
el sudo, el aptver,
el get, el el new,
poco más
y poco más. Es que es así.
Algo te hacen aprenderte un es que no
una frase entera de no tiene sentido. No
tiene.
A ver, porque es algo que cuando tú lo
haces así de continuo es que lo vas a
aprender sí o sí.
Claro, pero
no llevamos aquí toda la vida
trabajando,
¿no?
Vale. Eh, bueno, en teoría lo probamos y
esta sería en árbol, ¿vale? Y sí que ay,
¿cómo? ¿Cómo hago esto? Dios, espera. De
esta al server.
¿Qué ha pasado?
No tiene funcionaros. ¿Qué ha pasado
aquí?
Eh, ah, vale, que no le he asignado
direcciones IP, que me he puesto a
hablar. Se me ha ido el
Vale,
mañana lo miramos si os parece más.
Vale.
Sí.
Continuamos con más topologías.
Creo que es lo interesante de esta
evaluación realmente. O sea, es que no
modelo o sí también es importante. Eso
sí que
hace losos esquemas de que para qué
cada capa, ¿no? En que claro,
para qué sirve y ya está. Es que no no
tiene más. Es que no
eso será el más difícil.
Es es más complicadillo.
Luego ya os diré a ver qué material
podéis usar y o no en el examen. Vale,
vale. Esta la guardo. Mira, le voy a
poner, le voy a acabar de poner las
direcciones
y ya estaría, ya estaría. Ya, ya hemos
acabado la
Vale, pues adiós.
Venga, Álvaro, hasta luego.
Ahora no podrás abrir. Sí,
sí, castillo.
Vale, es que me está abriendo esto todo
el rato. A ver,
Dios.
Vale, le voy a poner las direcciones IP
a esto. Lo voy a
lo voy a dejar así presentable.
Vale, ahora, ahora sí.
Vale. 192.18
punto
1.2.168.1.3
tras
192 pun 168.1.4
vale
192.168.1
1.5
pun 168.1.6
y.168.1.7.
practicarlo, ¿vale? Porque
luego en el examen es más
es más complicado a la hora de, o sea,
estar familiarizados con qué es lo que
dónde están los los s, los h, los PCs,
los servers, los
Vale, y os será más fácil luego.
Vale, tiramos de aquí hasta aquí.
Perfecto.
Tiramos de este hasta este. Perfecto.
Y tiramos del server a este y perfecto.
Vale, en este caso el server, aunque sea
server, pero es uno más.
Otra cosa es que configuremos este
server como
como que está asignando Yeah.